DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
So today I want to practice
doing, computing some integrals
with you at polar coordinates.
So we have these three
integrals set up here.
And the way the integrals
are given to you,
they're given to you in
rectangular coordinates.
So the first thing
you need to do
is to re-express these
in polar coordinates.
And so for the
first one, part a,
I want you to completely
compute the integral.
For part b and c, we
have this function f,
which we haven't specified yet.
So the exercise is to
set up the integral.
We won't actually
compute it, we'll
just set it up completely.
So rewrite it in
terms of r and theta.
So why don't you pause the
video and get started on that.
And check back with me and
we'll work it out together.
Welcome back.
Let's get started.
So for all of these, when we're
transferring from rectangular
to polar coordinates,
the most difficult part
is understanding what region
we're integrating over.
And if we can understand
that, then the rest of it
is just straightforward
calculation.
So in part a, let's try to
think about what this region is
that we're given.
So we're given the region
from x equals 1 to x equals 2.
So let's draw those lines.
x equals 1 and x equals 2.
OK, so that's how x varies,
in between this band.
And now the y varies
from 0 to the function x.
So we'd better draw
the line y equals x.
OK, so this is the
line y equals x.
And the region that we're
after is in between this band
and in between these two lines,
so it's this region right here.
That's the region that we want.
All right.
So now that we
have that, what we
need to do to express something
in polar coordinates is
we need to sweep out
rays of constant angle,
and then measure the
radius along the ray.
So let's see what
I mean by that.
So we can kind of see that if
we're inside this region here,
the smallest value that theta
can be is just theta equals 0.
Because, for instance right here
is a point at theta equals 0.
And then theta runs
all the way up.
And this whole
line here is where
theta reaches its maximum, and
that's at theta is pi over 4.
So this tells us that it's
easiest to write the theta
integral on the outside.
And we're going to have theta
running from 0 to pi over 4.
OK, very good.
Now, in order to
get the r ranges,
it's going to be a
little bit more subtle,
because what we need to do is
we need to fix some arbitrary
theta in the middle here.
So I'll just draw kind of
a representative theta.
It would be like this one here.
So there is a
representative theta.
And what we need
to do is, we need
to describe how r varies
along this pink line here.
So that's the line
that we really want.
OK.
So in order to do
that, we just need
to do some simple
trigonometry now.
So let's see.
So r turns on at
this line right here.
At the line x equals 1;
that's where r turns on.
So let's see what the value
of r is at that line here.
So, the point is
that we have-- so
let me draw this triangle here.
Let me blow this triangle up.
OK.
So this is our line x equals 1,
and this is this triangle here.
We just put a
magnifying glass on it.
So we have this angle theta.
OK.
So this x-value is 1, because
we're on the line x equals 1.
So the length of this leg is 1,
and this is r that we're after.
OK?
So in basic trigonometry
we know that cos theta is
equal to-- so cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse--
is equal to 1 over r.
OK, so that tells us that
r is equal to sec theta.
OK?
So what that means is that
this, for any given theta,
this pink band turns on at
precisely r equals sec theta.
And so that's what we need
to write in the bottom here.
OK?
Now, you can see that it turns
off at r equals 2 sec theta.
Because now, instead
of going over length 1,
we go over length 2.
And so our integral becomes the
integral from 0 to pi over 4.
And r equals sec
theta to 2 sec theta.
OK, and now we
need to re-express
our original function
in terms of r and theta.
So our original
function was-- so let's
go back over to
the formula here.
So we have x squared plus
y squared to the 3/2.
So x squared plus y squared
to the 1/2, that's r.
And so x squared plus y squared
to the 3/2, that's r cubed.
So this is 1 over r cubed.
So this is 1 over
r cubed in here.
And as we know, dy dx
becomes r dr d theta.
OK.
So this is the integral
that we need to compute,
and now that we've
done all the geometry,
this is going to be a
straightforward integral
to compute.
So let's do it together.
I'll just rewrite it over here.
So we have theta running
from 0 to pi over 4,
and r running from sec
theta to 2 sec theta.
And we have 1 over r
squared, dr d theta.
OK.
So that equals-- taking
the inside integral first,
we get negative 1 over r from
2 sec theta to sec theta.
OK?
And now this is nice,
because sec theta--
if we plug it in for 1 over r--
it's just going to turn back
into a cosine, right?
So this is just the
integral from theta
equals 0 to pi over 4.
OK, because we have
this minus sign here,
we're going to get cos theta
minus-- 1 over 2 sec theta
becomes 1/2 cos theta-- d theta.
And this we can compute to be
the square root of 2 over 4.
So this is an elementary
integral that we can compute:
the square root of 2 over 4.
OK.
And that's it.
That's all there is to a.
So notice that the difficult
part is figuring out
how the boundary curves of
your original region re-express
in the r and theta coordinates.
So let's see if we can get more
practice with that on parts b
and c.
So in part b-- let
me just recall--
we're taking the
integral x equals 0 to 1.
And y equals x
squared to x, f dy dx.
So let's draw this region again.
So the bottom curve is y equals
x squared and the top curve is
y equals x, and x
runs from 0 to 1.
So this is the region
that we're after.
OK.
So once again in this
case, it's pretty easy
to figure out the
range for theta.
Because you see
this parabola here,
as it approaches the
origin, it becomes flat.
So the theta, as we get closer
and closer to the origin, is 0.
So the initial bound
for theta is 0.
It doesn't matter that we have
this curve here, it's still 0.
And then the top bound,
again, is pi over 4.
OK?
Now, for this curve, y equals
x squared, what we just
have to do is we
just have to use
our polar change of coordinates
and re-express this curve.
So y equals x squared.
Well, y is r sine theta.
And x is r cos theta.
So this is altogether r
squared cos squared theta.
OK?
And now all we need to do
is just solve for r here.
So we get r equals-- so I can
cancel that r with that one--
and it looks to me like we
get r equals tan theta secant
theta by solving.
OK.
So that's the r-value at each
of these points along the curve.
So that is going to
be our top bound.
So if we draw little
segments of constant theta,
they all start at r
equals 0, because we
have this sharp point
here at the origin.
And they all stop at this curve:
r equals tan theta sec theta.
All right?
And so now f we're just
going to leave put.
And then finally we
have r dr d theta.
OK.
So that's our answer to b.
All right.
Now c is going to be
a little bit tricky.
What's tricky about c
is drawing a picture,
but we'll see what
we can do about that.
So let me just remind
you. y ranges from 0 to 2,
and x ranges from 0
to the square root
of 2y minus y squared.
And then we have f dx dy.
OK.
Well, the y bounds are pretty
straightforward, 0 to 2.
This function, when
I first saw this,
I didn't recognize this
function right away.
So let's see what we can
make out of this curve.
So the top curve
for x is going to be
x equals the square root
of 2y minus y squared.
And this looks like it wants
to be the equation of a circle.
So let's see if we can turn this
into an equation of a circle.
So if we square both
sides of this equation,
then we get x squared
equals 2y minus y squared.
And now this over
here, 2y minus y
squared, so if we add this
over to the other side,
we have x squared plus y
squared minus 2y equals 0.
And now the thing that I notice
about this expression here
is it really looks almost like
the quantity y minus 1 squared.
Yeah?
If there were a plus 1 here,
then that would be the case.
So this is actually x
squared, plus y minus 1
squared-- except the
left-hand side is not
quite equal to that, it's
equal to that, minus 1.
So this equation just equals 0.
So this equation is just
equivalent to that one.
And that's good
news, because this
says that, this is
the equation if I add
this 1 over to the other
side-- let me go over here--
we have x squared, plus y
minus 1 squared, equals 1.
And this, we know what this is.
This is a circle which is
centered not at the origin,
but at the point 0 comma
1 in the y-direction.
So if we draw this, well,
this is the equation
for the entire circle.
But we only want
the positive half,
because we were told
that x starts at 0
and goes up to this
positive number.
So we only want the
positive half here.
OK.
So this is the region
that we're integrating.
And now that we know
this, we can again
figure out the values of
theta and the values of r.
So first of all, theta
is going to range again
from 0, because
this bottom curve,
as it comes into the
origin, it comes in flat.
So we have points of
arbitrarily small angles.
So theta is going to
start a 0, and theta
is going to go all the
way up until pi over 2,
because theta can be
pointing straight up.
OK?
And now we have to think about
these lines of constant angle,
and we need to think about
what r does in there.
So we can see from the picture
that r always starts at 0
and it stops at this curve.
So we need to figure out
what the r-value is along
this curve in terms of theta.
So what we want to do
is use the equation.
So we had it over here.
So x squared plus y
squared minus 2y equals 0.
So that was one of the
equivalent equations
that we got for our curve.
And now this is nice, because
this here is just r squared,
isn't it?
So this is r squared.
And this is minus 2y,
and y is r sine theta.
OK.
So we get r squared minus
2r sine theta equals 0.
Solving this for r, we get
that r is just 2 sine theta.
OK.
So r equals 2 sine theta.
That is the equation in r,
theta coordinates, which
describes this semicircle here.
And so altogether,
we get the range
is from r equals 0 to
r equals 2 sine theta.
And f just comes along for the
ride, and we have r dr d theta.
And I'll leave it at that.